one of the things that here's here's
something to think about with regards to
hitler
so because one of the things you might
ask is how the hell could he be so
so absolutely compelling to his
audiences but
here i'll give you an explanation so
let's let's make the
let's make a few assumptions and the
first assumption is
there are a lot of resentful germans
kicking around
why well they lost the first world war
that wasn't so good and then
there were a lot of brutal men left
because they'd been in the trenches and
they'd been shoot
fighting and shooting at each other
under absolutely abhorrent conditions
for like years and years and so there
were plenty of brutalized men around
um and then their whole damn economy
collapsed because they were forced into
signing what historians regard as a very
punitive peace treaty
and so like everything had fallen apart
to a degree that we can't even
begin to imagine and so you know in the
1930s the germans were starting to get
back on their feet and
and um when hitler came to power he
started not only to re-arm but to
reindustrialize the economy and he was
actually pretty damn good at that so
now hitler was a good orator but he but
he
it isn't exactly clear that he was a uh
coherent
philosophical theorizer although to
think of him as stupid is it is
completely missing the point he was by
no means stupid
um i wouldn't say that he was
particularly educated
but he had a very powerfully developed
aesthetic sense
and he spent a lot of his time designing
the cities that would be built after
world war ii was over and those cities
were generally
conceptualized by him as places where
the arts
or at least the nazi version of the arts
could flourish
you know so there's no real evidence
that what was wrong with the nazis was
that they weren't
civilized there's more evidence actually
i think that they were too civilized and
i'll talk to you about that later
but anyways you think how did hitler get
all these people
under his spell well here's a hypothesis
that's basically derived from union
thinking and i should let you know by
the way because sometimes jung has been
accused of being an anti-semite
and there's various reasons for this
partly because of what happened during
world war ii
and partly because his theory
drew heavily from christianity although
from many other sources as well
and he did believe that there were
differences in the psychology of people
with different ethnicities and now
you know whether that's racist or not
depends on whether or not you like the
person you're talking to because the
lefties
think that there are cultural
differences and they're important but if
you ever talk about them in the wrong
way then you're racist
and the right wingers well they just
think there are ethnic differences to
begin with
so it's a tricky it's a tricky issue if
there aren't differences that are
important then who the hell cares about
multiculturalism it's not even worth
preserving and if there are differences
well then you're stuck with having to
deal with the differences so you're
basically screwed either way
so anyways jung has been the target of
many accusations of anti-semitism
particularly by
biographers who were resentful and
clueless and historically uninformed
and i would say malevolent fundamentally
um he worked as a cia agent it was just
revealed last year and he
he he provided psychological reports to
the american government
on the underlying psychological
structure of the nazi leaders for years
and he never told anybody about that
while he was alive it only came to
light like it only came to light as far
as i know last year or perhaps the year
before that
so so anyways the germans you know they
weren't very happy about the whole damn
situation and so
when they were aggregating on mass you
think what happens when all people get
together in a group you know
we talked about that last time when we
talked about kierkegaard's idea that
as soon as you get a bunch of people
together no matter how truthful they are
all as individuals instantly the crowd
is not a truthful thing
and you know there are there are there
are real reasons for that real
psychological reason so there's the
famous ash experiments i hope that those
are the right experiments asch
about line length you know so you draw
two lines on the board and they're the
same length and
you get the the crowd to you know
collaborate with you and you ask some
poor sucker who doesn't know about the
game
uh to play and you know you ask one
person and they say no those
lines are different in length and you
ask another person they say well yeah
they're quite different in length and
another person says yeah
sure i can see the difference in length
and then you ask the poor pigeon
you know are they different in length
and he says
yes you know and you can understand why
it's like if all those other people are
saying it
there's either there's either something
wrong with all of them which seems
unlikely
or he's the victim of a conspiracy which
is a little on the paranoid side
but happens to actually be true in this
case um
or he's just not looking at it right and
you might think well the humble thing to
think is he's wrong
and so you know the fact that somebody
might go along with the crowd
you know you can you can you can blame
that on their
on their ability to be social and
conventional which in many ways is a
huge advantage because if you are all
anti-social and unconventional
you know i mean there'd be a good chunk
of you in jail and we certainly wouldn't
be
having this you know delightful peaceful
conversation that we're having so you
know you don't want to
underestimate the utility of
conventionality to too much of a degree
anyway so there's this funny story i
read once i don't think it's true but it
might be
where a psychology class got together
and decided they'd play a trick on the
professor
and the trick was that he would walk
back and forth they
and the trick was that they wouldn't pay
any attention to him at all if he was on
the left side of the room you know
they'd talk a bit and look
look up and if he was on the right side
of the room then they'd really focus in
and pay attention and
the story goes that by the you know by
several weeks of this little trick they
had him like lecturing right beside the
door you know and he wouldn't move from
that spot
and so the reason i'm telling you that
is because it's pretty obvious that
people can respond to the cues that a
crowd is delivering
you know and a good speaker does that
right so a good speaker does a variety
of things and one is he never talks to
the
to the crowd per se you know you pick
out specific individuals and talk to
them and they're sort of reflective of
the crowd
and then you can tell if everybody's
understanding and
the other thing that a good speaker does
is pay attention to the damn responses
of the crowd
because you know if if a lecture is
really a dialogue
even though the the audience is only
emitting non-verbal the non-verbal
elements of the conversation those
non-verbal elements those damn things
are important
so you want to stay in touch with the
non-verbal communications now
hitler he's kind of a chaotic guy you
know he's very angry he's angry in part
because he was a frustrated art student
he tried to get into art school
like four times so really the person to
blame
for world war ii was the four-person
committee that wouldn't let poor hitler
into the
i believe it was the viennese school of
art because he really wanted to go
you know and he had some artistic talent
he was a little on the conventional side
by all appearances but you know i've
seen some of his sketches and
you know he wasn't a complete [ __ ] and
he kind of felt maybe it would be okay
for him to go to university because he'd
just been through world war one you know
and that wasn't much fun
there's a story about hitler where he
was out on in the trenches and
he was there with all his buddies and he
wandered off to do whatever he wanted
off to do and when he came back they
were all dead because a bomb had landed
right in the middle of them and
you know you might think that would do a
little something to your psyche because
after an experience like that you're
either going to think oh man things are
pretty damn random and horrible or
there's pretty there's something pretty
damn special about me
because i wasn't killed by the bomb you
know maybe god has saved me for a higher
purpose i mean you can
be absolutely sure that if you went
through an experience like that that
something like that would be rattling
around in your mind
and he wanted he won a medal for bravery
you know so he got and then
after world war one he kind of wandered
around like a lot of men unemployed and
sort of like a [ __ ] you know he wasn't
very happy about that and
and you know no wonder so anyways
he didn't get into art school now he
didn't really have a fully developed
political theory you know
and but he was pretty good at speaking
so and there were lots of people who had
come
to just to hear him speak because people
were sort of trying to figure out what
the hell to do about all the chaos you
know
so then you think well what did hit what
was hitler good at
well okay now i'm going to switch to a
slightly different story and then i'll
get back to this one so
i don't know if you guys know about the
uh
the daycare scandals that that were very
very
common in the 1980s so
horribly common actually this infested
many towns and usually what would happen
is somebody
who is a little on the paranoid side or
maybe a lot on the paranoid side would
send their children
off to daycare and that was a whole new
thing in the 80s right because women
were
you know moving into the workforce like
mad and so they were handing over their
often their infants kids below three say
to total
strangers and you know for some of them
that set up a fair bit of worry like it
still does and sometimes that worry got
out of hand especially among the people
who are little on the
little predisposed to paranoid
schizophrenia and maybe even had had
some previous episodes and so
you know the kid would come home and the
mother would observe
or not something kind of peculiar about
their behavior and then she'd fantasize
about maybe what that was and then
you know she'd start asking the child if
the child had been touched in any
particular way and
you know and she'd keep this up for a
good length of time and then the child
would start to have nightmares
and then the child would tell the mother
about what the nightmares were and then
that would freak her out
so she'd ask even deeper questions and
soon you know her children were telling
her that
horrible things were happening to them
at daycare and so then she'd go to the
police and they wouldn't look into her
psychiatric background
and then the police would go out and
they'd start to interview other children
and if they interviewed them properly
then the other children would start to
produce all these stories as well
because the
now how did that happen well a bunch of
ways the first is
the police would ask leading questions
like
did anyone touch you well of course
someone touched the kids i mean people
touch kids
did anybody touch you there well that's
not a question
that's a piece of information the piece
of information is
if someone touched me there an adult
would be very interested in that
right so now what's a child doing when
he's answering an adult's questions well
the child doesn't bloody well know what
the hell do they know they're like
three you know they can hardly organize
their story
you know if you're talking to a kid and
you want to give get them to give you an
account of their day
you have to really guide them through
the organization of their memory
and partly what they're doing when
you're doing that is they're looking at
you
trying to figure out if they're telling
you the right things
which is what they should be doing
because what they're trying to learn to
do is to tell people things in a way
that they'll understand them but that
makes the child very very responsive
to the non-verbal and verbal cues of the
adult
you think about how fast those little
rats learn how to pick up language you
know
it's really very fast and no one really
teaches them they're just paying
attention like mad
so you get a bunch of cops who are on a
like a half-cocked adventure and they
think there's some serial sexual
pervert in their midst and they go
interview you know 15
20 kids and they do do do it a lot they
use little dolls and
they do it a lot and they do it a lot
and they do it a lot and sooner or later
all the kids start
having nightmares and then they start
telling the cops there's als these
terrible things happen like they're
taken into underground caverns and
they're stripped naked and they're
forced to
like leap frog over each other and like
you just can't believe it what happened
you can't
believe it it's all documented in a book
called satan's silence
which was written by a social worker and
a lawyer it's mind-boggling
the longest prison sentences in american
history
were handed out to a series of
middle-aged women
who were taking care of little kids and
the fbi even came up with a whole new
criminal category
late onset female sexual offender
well why didn't that category exist
before it's simple
there are no late onset middle-aged
female sexual offenders
that's why we didn't need the category
but once all these accusations came up
well poof you know you had to have some
damn category for these poor women some
of them were
put in jail for 350 years which seems a
bit excessive
given that they're only going to last
about 40 you know they get 12
consecutive life sentences so it and you
know there was
actually a situation where one town
went so far as to start digging
underneath the town
to find these underground satanic lairs
where all these weird ritual things were
going on
you know and along with this was not one
shred of collab
of concrete evidence you know when the
eventual conclusions
uh and this affected thousands of people
the eventual conclusions was
well there there actually isn't anybody
who's you know
satanically uh torturing children in day
care centers
now now anyways why am i telling you
this
well
what the children were doing you think
about how the hell did the children come
up with these weird ideas
you know i mean first of all we should
note the children are not stupid
and they can also dream up the most
horrible things you know
because they have an imagination that's
capable of extending itself out into the
terrifying now everyone knows that
because all you have to do is remember
when you were a kid
you know when you were hiding under the
covers because there were horrible
things in your dark room
you know you can populate the darkness
with monsters
with no problem and you should be able
to because there are monsters in the
darkness
even though your parents might tell you
there aren't it's like there might not
be any d monsters in that
particular piece of darkness and that's
a perfectly reasonable thing to tell
your children but
in the darkness as a whole it's like
yeah look the hell out
so this children aren't stupid now so
then the
the adults start to question them and
the kids are the back of their brain the
little imaginative part is thinking
what do these people want what do these
people want what do these people want
and so they'll throw them out a little
bit of information and they'll the
adults will perk up they'll
focus right on that piece of information
so maybe it's a cop who really hates
child satanist abductors which
you know it's a perfectly reasonable
stance and so
when the child offers any information
about
about the existence of such a thing
while the cop will perk up
and then the child thinks oh i see well
so sort of what's going on seems to have
something to do
they don't think this consciously you
know but their imagination is working
how do i model the reality that's been
presented to me
and that's when the dreams start to kick
in too okay
so by
speaking in the appropriate way
you can get all sorts of things churned
up in in the
in the unconscious minds of your
listeners
and by watching them as well you can
extract
out their unconscious desires
so now i'm speaking to you all and
you're all irritated because your life
has
been really awful for 15 years and i'm
saying this and i'm saying that and i'm
saying this and i'm saying that
you know and then i say something maybe
i say something uh
initially uh dismissive of
jews and you're all mad and there's two
or three people who go
yeah and then i think oh you know that's
kind of an interesting response and then
you know i'd lay out a couple more ideas
and some of them don't get any response
and others you know people perk right up
and
and i'm not stupid and i'm trying to get
the bloody attention of the crowd
and so if i do that
50 times the crowd's going to tell me an
awful lot about what they want
especially if i'm willing to follow them
and i can do that easily because
especially if i can start to work the
crowd a little bit because i can
capitalize on their emotional on their
emotional
capitalize on their emotions and the
display of that emotion and i can learn
to play that
and then that turns into a positive
feedback loop and so hitler's informing
the audience and the audience is
informing hitler and that's why
jung believed that hitler embodied the
shadow of the german people